an explosive moment for France
a teenager shot dead after police stop
his car in the Paris suburb of nontier
he had tried to drive off moments later
the car crashes a passenger is
apprehended
and a nation reacts
the policeman involved have both been
arrested but anger rapidly turned to
Fury and Fire
police came under attack and when the
fire brigade arrived they too are pelted
with rocks and fireworks
and it is all about this teenager
identified as Niel M 17 years old
mourned by his mother
I've lost the 17 year old child they
took my baby
he was still a child he needed his
mother
my phone
this morning he gave me
and told me he loved me I said be
careful and told him I love him
her son's killing lit a fire that has
long been simmering in Paris suburbs
where crime racism and mistrust of the
police are chronic problems
president macron said the shooting was
inexcusable his interior Minister called
for calm and promised a prompt
investigation into Nile's death
I want to have a thought for him for his
family and tell them that of course at
the interior Ministry and the National
Police we want to know as soon as
possible the truth about what has
happened but respecting the judicial
time
Paris is a city there's very customs of
protest and disorder but what happened
here in non-terre really carries Echoes
of serious writing that happened back in
2005. now that was also sparked by the
death of a young man at the hands of the
police and those riots went on for three
weeks
the French Capital has now seen one
night of violence of burnt out cars
confrontation and even an arson attack
on a Town Hall
the question is what happens next a
nation Waits nervously Adam Parson Sky
News